on n'a jamais
parler d'innovation on n'a jamais autant
pas
et d'expérience utilisateur c'est un
père marché qui devient un lieu de vie
dans lequel on peut s'asseoir sur un
fauteuil boire un café entre deux achats
c'est un chauffeur de vtc qui va vous
remettre une bouteille d'eau qui va vous
permettre de charger votre smartphone
aux états unis l'expérience yale est
devenu le premier critère de choix d'un
service digital devant le prix pour les
pure players du digital la recherche de
la meilleure expérience utilisateur est
profondément ancré dans leur adn
c'est un des deux piliers de la
disruption avec leur business model en
revanche pour la plupart des entreprises
traditionnelles
c'est à dire celles qui ne sont pas
nativement issus du monde du digital
basculer vers une logique de
l'expérience de l'excellence
expérientiel implique une transformation
en profondeur
une transformation du modèle
d'innovation pour le réorienter vers
l'expérience client pendant des années
l'expérience client était le parent
pauvre de l'innovation l'innovation
consistait à créer des nouvelles
fonctionnalités rajouter de nouveaux
services de nouvelles options
c'était l'âge d'or si on peut dire de
l'innovation fonctionnelle de la
fonctionnalité dans ce modèle la
différenciation entre un produit et un
service qu'il s'agisse d'une machine à
laver ou d'une carte bancaire
cette différenciation repose sur
l'ensemble des fonctionnalités qu'on va
pouvoir offrir aux clients l'ensemble
des services qu'il va y avoir dans ce
package et finalement à la limite on
serait même tenté de dire que est ce que
cette fonctionnalité va être utile à une
grande majorité des utilisateurs ou pas
au final cette question et secondaire
la fonctionnalité doit être visible
c'est un argument de vente
dans ce modèle là la raison d'être de
l'innovation c'est d'apporter en
permanence de nouvelles fonctionnalités
pour rendre obsolètes les produits des
générations précédentes et ainsi inciter
aurait achats on sent néanmoins qu'on
est à un point de bascule de ce modèle
je vais prendre un petit exemple une
télécommande télécommande de téléviseurs
un objet qu'on a touché soit une
télécommande de téléviseurs je sais pas
si vous êtes amusé à compter les boutons
c'est 50 boutons en moyenne 50 fonctions
et puis il ya quelques années à
l'initiative justement toujours des pure
players des digitales des télécommandes
beaucoup plus simple beaucoup plus
sobres sont arrivés sur le marché
concentrer sur les fonctions principales
et on sait que la nouvelle génération de
télécommande ne sera plus matérielles
elle sera vocale
comment est-ce qu'on interprète cette
évolution et bien tout simplement parce
que l'innovation n'échappe pas à la
logique de cycle et l'innovation
fonctionnel et très probablement arrivé
au bout d'un cycle
un cycle où finalement l'expérience
remplacerait la fonction les raisons
pour laquelle on arrive aux limites de
cet exercice de la fonctionnalité sont
les suivantes
d'un point de vue l'utilisateur
l'empilement de fonction rend
l'expérience d'usagé du service de base
de plus en plus compliqué les manuels
utilisateurs deviennent tellement épais
que plus personne ne les lit les
interfaces qu'elles soient physiques sur
les équipements électroniques se
couvrent de boutons et d'icônes qui sont
pas toujours évidentes les interfaces
digital deviennent des menus déroulants
qui s'étale sur plusieurs pages
c'est compliqué du point de vue de
l'entreprise
cette complexité issus des services que
l'on rajoute les uns aux autres cette
complexité des fonctions que l'on
rajoute ça également un coup une
incidence un impact sur le système
d'information parce qu'il faut bien
absorbé toute cette complexité
le coût unitaire des preuves et des
produits s'en ressent une télécommande
d'une cinquantaine de touche ça coûte 8
fois plus cher qu'une télécommande
basique donc que ce soit pour
l'utilisateur c'est compliqué pour
l'entreprise c'est cher et c'est
compliqué on sent qu'on est enfin qu'on
est en train d'arriver aux limites du
modèle
la deuxième raison qui ont fait que ce
modèle de l'innovation fonctionne est
arrivé aux limites
c'est une fois de plus l'arrivée des
pure players du digital qui ont fait
émerger un business à part donc qui ont
fait émerger un modèle d'innovation
alternatif basé sur l'expérience yale
si je poursuis avec la la logique de la
de la télécommande une télécommande
ce n'est ni plus ni moins qu'une
interface
or une interface on oublie toujours mais
c'est un obstacle un obstacle nécessaire
mais un obstacle entre un besoin je veux
voir un film et la réalisation du besoin
est dans une logique d'innovation
expérientiel on va chercher à rendre
cette interface cet obstacle le plus
intuitif possible le moins douloureux
possible de manière à ce que le client
l'utilisateur met dépense le moins de
temps pour accéder à ce dont il a envie
il ya quatre ans j'ai travaillé avec
netflix au lancement de ce service sur
nos décodeurs télé
inutile de dire qu'en termes
d'expérience utilisateur netflix est un
véritable pionnier mais ce qui m'avait
frappé à ce moment là
c'est qu'il y avait une fonctionnalité
que je trouvais intéressante qui
n'existait pas chez netflix
c'était le téléchargement c'est la
capacité de télécharger sur son
smartphone
une vidéo un film ou une série pour
pouvoir le regarder dans un avion citant
si on est en dehors d'une couverture eh
bien c'était pas fondamentalement un
problème pour pour netflix parce que si
on regarde et bien où est ce qu'on
regarde les vidéos ou est-ce qu'on garde
ses films et bien dont plus de 90% des
cas c'est chez soi la maison couverture
wifi donc en termes d'allocation des
ressources
netflix avait délibérément choisi de
mettre toute la priorité sur l' usage
principal qui était la visualisation de
films à la maison et ils traiteraient le
cas du téléchargement dans un second
temps dans un second temps donc explique
expertise sur l'expérience utilisateur
qu'ils ont déployés en priorité sur là
où le service était le plus utilisé
comment est ce que l'on met en oeuvre un
modèle d'expérience un modèle
d'innovation expérientiel c'est quelque
chose de global qui va concerner
l'ensemble des entités de l'entreprise
mais il ya trois points clés
premièrement la simplicité
là où le modèle d'innovation fonctionnel
va chercher à empiler les fonctions on
l'a vu le modèle d'innovation
expérientiel va rechercher à se
concentrer sur les fonctionnalités sur
les services les plus simples c'est le
back to basic
deuxièmement l'innovation expérientiel
est un processus qui concerne tout le
monde dans l'entreprise
l'expérience d'un utilisateur elle est
globale elle part de la découverte du
service jusqu'à l' usage en passant par
l'achat voir la réclamation est donc en
conséquence
là où dans un modèle d'innovation ou
fonctionnel on pouvait laisser des
départements des directions gérer cette
innovation en revanche 120 modèles
d'innovation expérientiel c'est bien
toute l'entreprise qui est impliqué
troisième chose on ne peut pas imaginer
de faire de l'innovation expérientiel
sans mettre le client au centre on le
doit le retrouver dans toutes les étapes
du processus d'innovation
dès la conception avec du design
thinking du test de prototypes de la b
testing et dans l'amélioration continue
en se nourrissant des feedbacks clients
au final l'innovation obéit à cette
règle des cycles à cette notion de cycle
et on voit bien qu'on est en train de
basculer progressivement d'un système
d'innovation basé sur la fonction à un
modèle d'innovation basé sur
l'expérience pour une entreprise
traditionnelle
l'enjeu c'est une transformation en
profondeur pour être en mesure
d'adresser cette ce nouveau modèle
d'innovation pour y arriver il va
falloir faire preuve d'énormément de
conviction et énormément d'innovation il
faut réapprendre l'innovation réinventer
l'innovation je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]